salve a tutti bella tutti iraq e come
quanta gente che c'è qua ciao ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono
parigi oggi siamo su the shell ve lo
ricordate che era un gioco paurosissime
bellissimo dove mi sono appena
schiantato era veramente stupendo e
l'hanno fatto l'hanno messo anche online
su b12 gente che fa trick e robert ecco
io io io o meglio sono le faccia l'avevo
portato tanti anni fa anche questo
ovviamente sono molto nostalgico non so
se sono baldo stavo guardando che hanno
aggiornato un sacco di roba ad esempio
il personaggio muore meglio c'è una
palla l'ho presa c'è un sacco di nova
ves a cosa che c'è gente mi trig era
troppo raga ma posso fare un trick senza
morire chelsea possibile tra aveva si
scandalizza non si può perché devo
prendere bene a posto che dovevo
prendere non si può fare una gara una
gara tutti insieme qualcosa del genere
perché bellissima sta roba che c'è gente
c'è il fatto che ci sia gente una roba
stupenda barons o poi ma di cosa troppo
mamma mia niente ci avevo fatto premi
stabilizzeranno stessa era ok lo faccio
non c'e scelta che qualche figo arrivo
venite amici quanta gente che ci gioca
ma che bello della gara bellissimo sono
troppo contento era da solo l'ultimo
terzo giocato madonna pesano tra l'altro
sono bravissimo cioè non solo non sia
possibile sta roba su un fenomeno
salve sono morto ma me lo sono meritato
e con onore anche perché guardaroba fa
in tre 62 volte lo fa
questo non è un fantasy questa era una
60 una volta non farlo la seconda volta
quindi io devo seguire gli obiettivi che
è stata la va bene questo era un 360 con
backflip deve arrivare al traguardo
almeno cosa abbastanza semplice
teoricamente pesa questo gioco qua e non
sto scherzando c'è anche per per il guar
l'ho provata una volta stanno un po mita
non sto scherzando ovviamente ecco il
traguardo legambiente al traguardo ti
puoi schiantare non succede niente
perché ormai preso very nice
questo volevo anche prima mi chiama
fallo subito varie roba per h picchio io
le dico se robert rivelare la mia vita e
vedere se succedono robe bruttissime
tipo che rischiamo però non è socio e
strano non è successo cosa fai sei pazzo
quelle pazzo è pazzo ho fatto una roba
che non voleva va bene c'è un pò ripido
quali non vorrei dire ma per me è un po
rischioso la vedo un po dura però aveva
niente abbiamo lo stesso non salivo da
qualche parte così bruxelles si parlava
un cacchio guardai c'è parigi che guida
c'è il sì spesso view
e che ne so io non lo dici ecco questo
era col vr immaginatevi sta roba io dopo
un minuto sta vomitando per casa e non
sto scherzando veramente vorrei dirvi
che uno scherzo non è uno scherzo sta
vomitando stato linea ok quasi quasi
come giocare a titanic in val bene c'era
una roccia sola ho preso quello turco
main hubble e va beh questa è proprio
bellissima anche dabo betclic camagüey
rai ma anche questa come visuale non è
male e ragazzi non è male per niente
soprattutto vedo cosa sta succedendo
cosa che non vedevo prima quindi ancora
meglio
ok mi sono salvato per miracolo ma vai
piano vai piano e piazza arrivato però
pare però è un po troppo ma drone
hayward beh ho parcheggiato la bici non
si può dire il contrario beh ragazzi
sono tornato nella zona principale
voglio vedere che cosa c'è dopo le
montagne qua perché mi sono messo a sali
tutta sta roba
beh quella è quella è la zona dove si
sposa e adesso sta andando di sopra
perché vuoi vedere che cacchio c'è qua
sopra
non c'è una sega montagna finisce c'è un
mondo voto va bene
orami come di ritornare loro prima
madonna e casinò
pensavo ci fosse più la ma attenzione è
un albero solo cielo fiat e quello ma
dai
vabbè peccato perché mi ferite che calzi
cirri cioè si è schiantata il duemila
all'ora ma a venirti poiché ci ha voluto
lo sfocato ste robe una volta però non
so se mi sono rimasti salvataggi
effettivamente con meno mi sono rimasti
cosa fa questo ma cosa fai
ma cosa spinge mi chiamo ti seguo vedi
qua eh vabbè è morto niente non puoi
starne anche con una persona questo
gioco che subito si ammazzava beh non
volevo fare questo comunque non meritava
di essere visto che meritava il tipo che
spinge la palla di pieno quelle che ho
scaricato dove cacchio sono aveva il
caos facciamo baikal madonna raga ma
state scherzando
ma cos'è polgai scola bce paper moto ma
se lo faccio sul corrimano tipo vediamo
sul corrimano era il modo giusto
perfetto e mettete un check point vi
prego perché se no non ci si arriva più
guai lo dico c'è una barba ho capito ma
ragazzi ma mette potete mettere gli
ostacoli più vicini perché non ci si
arriva a non va abbastanza veloce la
bici proprio non va veloce la bici non
ci si arriva ecco perché vedo che
l'applicazione migliorata a meno che non
salti mezzo bene madonna c'ero c'è uno
zio la giunta c'è un tipo c'è un tipo e
vediamo come fanno gli altri ragazzi
l'unica bellissima ce l'ho fatta ciao
frate ti segua a ruota
scherzavo a ok quasi a ok ti vuoi
piazzare i check point va bene e sì
perché sono impossibile raga suonandoli
non fa niente sto andando all'indietro
lt più belle ville posto c'è poi trave
ricordiamocelo ci sono l tpl
ok dice poi promesso laga un fenomeno o
un fenomeno non sono affatto l'altro ci
ha messo due ore che porta roba va bene
e siamo arrivati fin qua che non è male
che non è ma non avevo visto che devo
saltare
non immaginavo questa cosa vediamo se ci
arrivò senza passare la fisica è
bellissimo
no siamo più dovuto perfetto perfetto le
tpl let's go con c'è poi si va lontano
raga con c'è poi si ma lontanissimo però
è bellissimo la caserma è meglio che è
meglio nel parkour di gta ragazzi a
saperlo devo invitare quel tipo step
pietro ciccio a giocare online a questa
cosa voglio vedere cosa succede
sarà incredibile bongiorno dub don come
andiamo stop nostro passato meglio io
sopra una tensione come non detto perché
poi c'è una roba difficilissima ok e
vabbè ma devo via che come si sa non
riesco neanche a c'entra la visuale io
come faccio
ragazzi questa parte un questa parte un
disastro proprio
l'ho fatto mamma mia mamma mia ma fa
male ma chissà com'è pirletti allora
allora allora allora allora allora
allora proprio lui
mamma mia come se la gestisce il fabi e
ci ho messo un botto ma fa niente
dettagli e cioè torno indietro a dietro
gli altri livelli
ok dai dai che pian piano lo finiamo non
so come non so come l'abbia piano lo
finiamo che hai finco ok fico ok
fin qua ok bellissimo questo l'ho fatto
subito senza neanche morì una volta
perfetto non era così difficile ma non
era neanche scontato e ragazze tensione
questa è dura arco demonio questo è un
altro di quelli dove non arrivò al
finale lo so io credo di continuarlo
porterò un altro episodio perché il
proprio bello non avevo visto la modesta
porterà un altro episodio di the scender
sa il 300 per cento
niente ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
come se un certo punto mi piace anche ai
socialisti della descrizione e mente ci
sto provando jorge è più forte di me
anche sotto avuto un giorno qua noi come
sempre ci vediamo
tornerò a prenderti quanto è vero che
esisto tornerò a prenderlo
[Musica]